[Music]
thank you thank you for taking the time
no thank you uh for for stopping by here
not a big deal from for me yeah it is a
big deal for me
what are we
what's going on
i wanted to talk to you i want to talk
to you about a bear a bear a bear a bear
okay a bear uh what what if we had a
bear judd and then magicians like kind
of like evil siegfried and roy they
capture him and they put him in a cave
and then he learns magic yeah and then
he becomes the first
bear magician we call it bear gishen
i'm sorry my assistant didn't even tell
me why you were driving by i thought you
were just gonna drop by to hang out i
want to pitch some movies i thought you
were like putting your focus on the talk
show no no i don't really care about the
talk show i want to make movies that's
just a springboard marginism is a real
film i'm seeing pixar 3d
i'm not pixar yeah okay um
it's a frog a frog is uh you know
hopping about and he gets scooped up
in a mason jar he learns magic
jonah hill
is
fragician froggition
okay usually
the movies that we work on they're not
science fiction and they're not like
animals who talk they're usually just
about people stupid human stories yes an
eel is swimming and then they a net for
a butterfly but they put it in the water
and they capture the eel you'll
no no that one's called illusionist the
eel it's not a genre i understand how
about uh this is 50. this is 50.
no the 50 year old virgin no this is 60.
nope here is a 60 year old virgin i
thought that you had a lot of ideas i do
do you have anything else that's not
sci-fi magic or something
okay there's a man he's 22 he gets
married okay because he's religious and
then six years later his wife cheats on
him with a small italian man
and uh and then i get my heart broken
but i learn life lessons hmm
that that doesn't seem like a comedy at
all that just seems
tragic and
sad that's mine
that's that was that's my life that's
too sad see i think no one would want to
see that because it's just so sad but
i'm over it look at me i don't know if
you are over it you have this whole
stance of
positivity but you can feel the pain
is right there and it throws me but then
i like redefine my faith and start
stripping a bunch of random broads
that's even sadder
okay if you don't want to make one of my
movie ideas yeah maybe we could find
some middle ground i could be in one of
the movies you're already gonna make i
don't hold auditions
i just watch people on tv and if i like
them i hire them have you ever seen my
show i did see one of them
i don't think i don't say this that
often
everyone has to be jewish
at least the guys the girls could not be
jewish but the guys have to be jewish i
can't be in a jet appetite well you
can't be the lead you could be a friend
i
can't stress this enough i whatever i'm
lacking i'll do whatever you need me to
do i'll do i'm i'm a big fan i just i
just want to be
i just want to be in a movie with with
you with you well i got to figure out
like what you do yeah would you do full
frontal what i'd call nudity yeah jason
siegel did it in forgetting sarah
marshall and i think i could i could
also have comedy penis how does it look
because i'd have to see it before
we do it because you don't want to get
on a set and not know what it's going to
be because if it's weird looking the
joke doesn't work it only works if it's
just like almost like a textbook looking
penis it's thin or long and left what
about the testicles bigger than you'd
want them
yeah i would have to see it i just have
to see it just to know how freaky it was
okay
can you
can we
yeah can you guys honestly just honestly
can you just go outside just one
oh no that's not so far left it just it
just seems that's because the ball on
the right is so long
[Music]
you